thanks to Samantha now it's taken more
than six years but the chilcot inquiry
into the Iraq war could be published
within weeks the report is expected to
be handed to government officials
tomorrow before then the security
checking begins but one of the most
influential conservative MPs has warned
there will be uproar if that takes more
than a fortnight well that man is of
course David Davis the former Foreign
Office minister and he's with me now in
a very good morning to you mr. Davis so
you think what a couple of weeks we
should finally see Chilcott what about
the referendum campaign you don't think
it would have an impact on that it's got
nothing to do with a referendum campaign
I mean though both sides are implicated
the Tory supported it the Labour
government went went for it is it worth
of the Iraq war that is so there's no
political dimension it's got nothing to
do with Europe you so one of the few
things that has got nothing to do with
hero so it should take at most two weeks
to security get remember everything in
it's already being poured over by white
tautly number of times and there's worry
that that number ten a few weeks ago
started saying oh well with this being
June and July why and is we still in the
era of hot LED typesetting I'm in there
even if it doesn't you know it hasn't no
no no particular bearing on the
decisions made in the you ever and if it
drives it out but would that be there
will be no bad thing for a while look I
mean we have been talking about Europe
now for two months and we've got at
least another month to go month and a
half to go so yeah people will talk
about other things I mean and and this
is very important and it's fundamental
to decisions taken in Libya in Syria in
Iraq it's also incredibly important to
the families of the soldiers at 179
soldiers who died who are going through
agony being made to wait for closure
well you mentioned Syria there and I
know you've just come back from a trip
there and seen president so we'll get on
to that in a moment or two but just on
Chilcott are you all so worried given
this process that the checking security
vetting process is been gone through it
has already been Maxwell eyes so to
speak those people that are mentioned
parts criticized within it about a
chance to respond d are you worried that
it might pull its punches I would think
it's unlikely
the maximization process was a
negotiation process and it shouldn't
have been I mean they they employed at
your expense of mind taxpayers expense
very expensive lawyers to defend the
reputations of generals and politicians
and so on that's not what is supposed to
be about its supposed to be our
fact-checking says a possibility that
that's that's blunt at the edge but i
think you know Chilcott must understand
this is probably the last thing is going
to do a public life if this is a
whitewash it will be seen as a whitewash
it will be described as a white washing
his reputation will go the way of
something rights a white wish I don't
think so I think every incentive is
there for him to to get it right okay EU
referendum well the government viewers
we remain and wheeling out the big
economic guns in recent days unen deed
coming up we are told a treasury report
gonna warn about all kinds of things
including recession job losses and
stephen crab saying today that we could
see have an economic effect as big as
that from the banking crash in 2008 big
project fear is building up yeah and you
know in many many decades ago a sort of
a sort of name taken by Manny rice Davis
said they would say that wouldn't and
I'm afraid that's the way the public had
begin to see this we've had the IMF last
week well yeah IMF is not an impartial
organization dominate Lagarde the head
of it i'll christine lagarde wrist that
beg your pardon miss delia rolling two
into one I beg your pardon Christine
Lagarde has been it was involved in the
setting of the terms for Greece and now
admits by the way they got it wrong so
all this sort of the international
establishments rolling out the the
stories to try and support the
government line on this I think the
public are going to say actually it's
our decision we believe what we want to
believe and he said of misuse of
resources and we've had the row about
their the overall leaflet in the nine
point three million pounds that cost
nearly is another game you're all going
to government the Treasury being used to
like this if there's a really serious
problem for the government in this in
that the public will begin to think
they're cheating you know they they
spent you say millions on on that
leaflet they're diverting resources
they've got a large unit being set up
especially at number 10 for this is
beginning to look like propaganda
rather than proper government and what
do you think then on that if it's a
tight vote but remain win and people
have that view the people particularly
in the Conservative Party who lost who
wanted to leave like you will that alter
their attitude to the Prime Minister is
leader I'm not sure about that but I
think what it will do is it'll it'll
make the referendum as a Scottish one is
a never ending is going to come back you
know this was supposed to resolve this
thing for 30-40 years if not forever in
truth it will it will it will continue
to haunt and you mr. Cameron's future
Ken Clark a call saying if he loses 30
seconds I don't agree with I mean I
think the the simple truth is that if
brexit wins more accurately then there
will be an argument that you know the
people have been arguing against it
can't we negotiate it but the plenty of
people around he can appoint put in
charge and say they've got well
basically sole power over this very very
important negotiations that could be
done hold on Lee said I mean that would
be the most fundamental thing facing the
United Kingdom its future relations with
your opinion so you've got a prime
minister there who is a first name lame
second name dark I don't think sorry
it's it's fundamental it's not running
the whole country but it is fundamental
the future of the country but then
that's that's where we are I mean that's
simply what's going to happen I think
okay and who would you any personalities
were lined on the early side well we've
got Boris Johnson Michael Gove Theresa
Villiers we know you've got your big on
non-stop list of them as a very tockman
there that that were that were signed up
from Canada so so I don't think there's
a problem finding something to do it and
it did in the middle ranks of government
there are other people who are very much
on site one or two like Dominic Raab who
have been who've been negotiators for
the country in the past so you could
actually populate a whole department
with people really but there were
Chinese Walton the Prime Minister is not
allowed no or not allowed get involved
or not allowed have you know I don't
think that don't think that but I think
if you are going to have a negotiator
you appoint somebody who really believes
in it really wants to do it really wants
to succeed and have spent the last three
months at least if not the last several
years thinking about how this will work
which is pretty much all the brexit team
been doing okay now I want to move on
Syria because it's a very important
information and insight into
the thinking of President Assad first of
all why did you want to go and see him
because you know a lot of people are
saying we should engage with the other
monsters look at the moment we that the
biggest issue is Europe as it turns out
is maximal migration and terrorism and
we're on our own estimates not the
Syrian isthmus our own estimates there
are about a thousand jihadis a year
arriving in Europe from Syria the Syrian
agencies think it's three times that so
give you an idea of the size that's
overwhelming our ability to deal with
that as we see with Brussels and Paris
and so on so we have to go back to the
source and fix this at sauce which is
why I went out the current policy the
options the outcomes going to be one
either the jihadist win which actually
be a disaster absolute disaster wipe
away the sort of liberal Society in
Syria's not a liberal state its liberal
society secondly there is a sort of very
very long negotiation for every year the
negotiation goes on at another thousand
terrorist is another ten twenty a
hundred thousand migrants or the Syrians
win and if the sorry the Syrian
government wins and if the Syrian
government wings and it's only the
Russians talking to them they're not
going to sort out their torture murder
of prisoners and general attitude to the
population so my view is we need to get
a grip on this somehow we need to get
our hand on the table as well our card
in the deck and that's why I went to
find out one the attitude I mean you say
there you know the influence that the
Russian side now how did they do that by
supporting Assad militarily generally
you're not saying that Britain shouldn't
go that far but have to get involved
with the Assad regime I asked said I
also sad that about the relationship
with the Russians had asked him actually
why they've downscaled their activities
and he gave their interesting answer he
said that is because they were being
accused of stymieing the negotiations by
giving so much support actually they
still getting a lot of support the
Russian soldiers there the Russian
pilots when I was there and so on but
but what was interesting is Putin said
to Assad we will not let you loose now
that's going to alter that alters a
complete complexion the attitude the
Syrian government the
stitute of the other players in the
games were the Saudis and Katara's and
so on it seems to me you've got a
country that's nearly destroyed hundred
billion dollars of damage minimum to the
infrastructure what we should be looking
at is a global marshall plan to put this
country back together again it used to
be the Germany of the Middle East
Germany of the Levant you know the the
breadbasket the textile industries
pharmaceuticals you name it if we said
that then that gives us a card to play
as well as something to do about do we
say for the time being President Assad
you're the one to leave that got 11 is
she one of the problems here and it is
difficult what the war is done is
polarized the population and they're
very large number was so terrified of
the jihadists that there now supporters
of the sad one of the best NGO people I
sort somebody there who was who was
actually running one the most important
NGOs and he said you know if there's an
election tomorrow sad would win easily
so that's the problem we gotta put
democracy in place we're going to change
the behavior of the Syrian government
that's the most important thing save the
syrian people from the torture and the
killings that go on and actually use it
to get Western influence back in this
important country